five years after South Sudan became
independent there is still no peace in
the world's youngest nation these people
are among the latest displaced by a
fresh wave of violence in the Western by
a gazelle region they fled the town of
raja after it was attacked by an unknown
armed group following months of mounting
tensions among the area's tribes I own
in karo jaan jaan when we heard the
gunshots my family and I we ran away to
hide in the bush when we were in the
bush in the shooting didn't stop we
started walking for five days we walked
to get here thousands of people have
been displaced by the fighting in raja
they left with just the clothes on their
backs and have yet to receive any aid
joke about you got my two children their
sin because they haven't had anything
proper to eat all we're eating our wild
fruits we have nothing no shelter no
food and no mosquito nets here like a
mini and you can make it up with job the
rise of localized conflict has made
South Sudan civil war more complex raja
used to be a peaceful town since the
soldier who has been based there for
five years and was shot in the hip
during the most recent attack ya know
this was the first time there was never
an attack like this in raja they came in
very big numbers we weren't quite sure
how many well I didn't if I my idea
come fighting erupted amid growing
tensions over a controversial decree to
reconstitute South Sudan's ten states
many believe the new 28 states will
benefit the Dinka the country's largest
ethnic group the new administrative
boundaries left Rajas local tribes the
minority in a new think a dominated
state they are unsatisfied group and
unset of our group sons and daughter of
the area that might have got themselves
into this fight that happened in raja
they have their own commander they have
their own person who has been
spearheading that does not want Raja to
be a part of any other group except to
be made alone as its own state five
years after independence from sudan not
much seems to have changed for the
average South Sudanese their new country
continues to be plagued by violence
hunger and displacement the peace deal
signed almost a year ago between the
government and the rebels is hanging in
the balance at the same time new armed
groups risk further destabilizing this
young fledgling nation